The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Basically, you're
not going to able to use Beatles
clip, unfortunately.
But can I hear what the song is?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So the
reason why this
is under Creative Commons--
which, it's a little sketchy.
I'm not sure if
they ligitimately
could have done that.
But it's because they've
transformed it so much,
to the extent that it's, like,
no longer the original work,
right?
So if you revert it
to the original work,
then you're also
reverting-- you,
like, taking away the Creative
Commons work basically.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And you like this instrumental?
STUDENT: Uh huh.
PROFESSOR: You
could find something
like this on ccMixter or
a different music archive.
It'll take a while,
and unfortunately I
don't have a short cut.
That's a problem with
music, is that it's not
catalogued very well.
So it's time consuming,
because you just
have to listen to everything.
STUDENT: What would be, like,
a good mood to search for that?
PROFESSOR: I wouldn't
necessarily search by mood.
I would search by
instrumentation.
STUDENT: OK.
PROFESSOR: So, have you looked
at any of those links that
were up on the syllabus?
STUDENT 1: Uh huh.
PROFESSOR: I mean, this is sort
of, like, chill rock basically.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: And that may not
actually narrow it down.
Go ahead and try to
explore other genres, too.
I-- unfortunately,
there's no quick algorithm
for finding good music.
That's why it's
so time consuming.
But let me see what
you've got cut so far.
STUDENT 1: OK, the video?
All right.
PROFESSOR: Do you mind if
I bump up your brightness
a little bit so I
can see it better?
STUDENT 1: Oh yeah.
And I'll delete
this song for now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, what do snowflakes and
cell phones have in common?
Well, let me start by
drawing a snowflake first.
First, I'm draw an
equilateral triangle,
divide each side
into three parts,
and draw another equilateral
triangle on top of each one.
Then, take out the middle
and repeat the process.
This time with one,
two, three, four,
times three, which is 12 sides.
Eventually, the shape will start
looking something like this.
In mathematics this is
called a Koch snowflake.
If I repeated my
process again and again,
I would see this same
pattern anywhere I looked.
This is a Koch
snowflake, this time--
STUDENT 1: And this
would be an animation.
I just haven't inserted it.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
- --that on any scale, on any
level of zoom look roughly
the same, are called fractals.
Computer scientists can
program these infinite patterns
by repeating an often
simple mathematical process
over and over.
In the 1990s, a radio
astronomer named
Nathan Cohen, used
fractals to revolutionize
telecommunications
At the time, Cohen was having
troubles with his landlord.
The man wouldn't let him
put an antenna on his roof.
So Cohen designed a more
compact, fractal radio antenna
instead.
The landlord didn't notice
it, and it worked better
than the ones before.
Working further, Cohen
designed a new antenna.
This time, using the fractal
called the Menger sponge.
The Menger sponge is
not really the sponge
you'd be scrubbing
your bathroom with.
But you can still
think of it like that.
Imagine both water
and soap getting
through your sponge's holes.
Except the water is Wi-Fi and
the soap is, say, Bluetooth.
The fractal's
infinite sponginess
allows it to receive many
different frequencies
simultaneously.
Before Cohen's
invention, antennas
had to be cut for one frequency.
And that was the only frequency
they could operate at.
So without Cohen's
sponge, your cell phone
would have to look a hedgehog
to receive multiple signals,
including the one your
friends use when they call.
Cohen later proved that
only fractal shapes
could work with such a
wide range of frequencies.
Today, millions of wireless
communication devices--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: Oh, sorry my bad.
PROFESSOR: Oh, was
that the music?
STUDENT 1: I was
testing something.
PROFESSOR: OK, I was
like, what's happening
when you guys were recording.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, I'm
going to delete that.
Come on.
PROFESSOR: Here, let's go--
STUDENT 1: It was
like-- earlier.
Somewhere up there-- this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --genuis invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the w--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Why is it doing this.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, you
can just do this.
And it's around here.
I guess it's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --including laptops and
bar code scanners used
Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
It tuns out, nature has been
doing it the whole time,
and not just with snowflakes.
Natural selection favors
the most efficient systems
and organisms, often
of a fractal shape.
For example, the spiral fractal
is present broccoli, seashells,
and hurricanes.
The fractal tree is
relatively easy to program,
and can be used to study
river systems, blood
vessels, and lightening bolts.
So many natural systems
previously thought off limits
to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals.
Plus, mathematics allows us to
learn nature's best practices,
and then apply them to
solve world problems.
Much like Cohen's antenna
revolutionized the field
of telecommunications,
other fractal research
is changing medicine,
weather prediction,
and building design-- here
at MIT, and everywhere
in the world.
Look around you.
What beautiful
patterns do you see?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: All right,
that's a good start.
Good start.
So I think in general,
the transitions
could be a little bit tighter.
So, like right here.
When you walk off-- well, this
hiccup up is really noticeable.
So either hide it by
having an extreme close up
before you leave, or just
get rid of this entirely.
Although, I know that you did
that to show the walk off,
so that you could
show walking in.
STUDENT 1: And I can
connect-- this is actually
one video I separated so
I could speed this up.
And I guess I was just
playing around with that.
PROFESSOR: I almost think this
happens too quickly, though.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, it's
at 140 right now.
So I was just like--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I would
slow it back down, yeah.
So let's go scene by scene.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Is this track Creative Commons?
STUDENT 1: No, it's Aerosmith.
I would take that out.
I was just looking
for an interem--
PROFESSOR: There's probably an
iMovie sound effect, actually,
that you could use.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: For this part,
where you're just, like,
walking around, I would
digitally zoom in close up.
Because otherwise, you jump
to talking all of a sudden.
But your movement wasn't
exaggerated enough
to where you, like, get the
joke that you're talking.
So you can exaggerate it by
changing the actual framing
of the scene.
STUDENT 1: So would I zoom
in when I start talking?
PROFESSOR: I would stay
zoomed in when you're talking,
and then clean cut to a
wider shot of you afterwards.
So basically, I would
cut, like, right there.
I don't remember
how-- my version's
a little but
different than yours.
But I would cut right there.
And for the preceding
clip, do you know
how to crop and zoom on clips?
STUDENT 1: Yeah, I can.
PROFESSOR: You just go
like that, basically.
Yeah, for that.
Now, for this I
would also-- this
is basically one,
really long shot that
is framed the exact same way.
And it's very lectury,
because you're literally
at a blackboard.
Although I think that that was
a good set up for you guys,
given the complexity
of explaining this.
But I think you can avoid making
it sound too chalkboard lectury
by cutting in and
out of your frame.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: Or, of your framing.
So this is fine.
Like right there, I
would save your audio
but just cut to a close up
of your hand drawing it.
Does that make sense?
STUDENT 1: So kind of
like with the phone?
When I'm showing--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah--
I would do more of that.
I think in general, you
have very static shots
that last for a long time.
So you can break that up
by keeping the same track
from your one long take,
but mixing the extent
to which you've zoomed in.
STUDENT 1: OK, yeah, that's
what I did with the phone,
so I can definitely
work on that.
PROFESSOR: I think
that would help.
Because this section
is pretty long.
Like, if you just even
look at your project,
this file is 32 seconds.
STUDENT 1: Which, it's-- the
video is about three minutes
and 40 seconds right now.
PROFESSOR: OK.
STUDENT 1: And then,
like, this part
is because I inserted the song.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK, great.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --repeated my process
again and again,
I would see this same--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: So I guess you could
zoom in at "this same shape."
PROFESSOR: I actually--
I feel like you're
revealing this image too
soon in your sentence.
"If I repeated this process
over and over again,
I would see this image."
And I almost don't
want to see the image
until you say "this image."
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: So maybe if you
can zoom in, and frame,
and crop out the fractal
zoom in until you say "this."
And then at "this" you can
either pan to the drawing,
or you can cut to a wide shot.
STUDENT 1: OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-If I repeated my
process again and again,
I would see this same
pattern anywhere I looked.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And
anywhere you looked--
I mean, is there a
way to, like, shoot
footage of just close
ups of the snowflake?
Of you, like, going around
the edge of the periphery
of the snowflake?
STUDENT 1: So that
would this part.
PROFESSOR: That would
be that part, OK.
STUDENT 1: Yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is Koch snowflake--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: Which, this is a
software-- a fractal drawing
software.
Am I allowed to, like,
film the zoom in on that?
And then use--
PROFESSOR: It depends
on what license
the software is released under,
and who created that image.
STUDENT 1: OK.
So, I mean, I didn't have
to pay for it or anything.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
created the image.
STUDENT 1: No.
Well-- so, kind of.
It's just a software.
And then you can do-- let's
say you draw a Koch snowflake,
and then you can
just zoom in on it.
And then I just--
PROFESSOR: And that is are
free, open source software?
STUDENT 1: Yeah, it was free.
PROFESSOR: You know,
what you should do is?
You should just take a QuickTime
recording of your screen.
Like what we were doing.
STUDENT 1: That's what
I was going to do.
PROFESSOR: And just, like,
do a QuickTime recording
of you zooming in.
STUDENT 1: And that's OK to use?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
All
STUDENT 1: Right.
PROFESSOR: Oh wow,
this is so trippy.
How do I make it stop?
STUDENT 1: I don't
actually know.
I haven't worked too
much-- there is actually
a video of somebody doing
that, which is well done.
So I may use part of that.
PROFESSOR: You-- ideally, you
would make your own video.
STUDENT 1: Yeah,
I'll work on that.
Maybe I'll just, like, track
their movements at least.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because I don't
know what the details of that
would be.
If you're actually
allowed to use a video.
Unless they've
specifically released it
under Creative Commons.
All right, so you're here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is a Koch snowflake.
This time, drawn on a computer.
Such never ending patterns
that on any scale,
on any level of zoom
look roughly the same
are called fractals.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, this is where
you change your wardrobe
all of a sudden.
Ideally, that wouldn't happen.
Wardrobe changes are
OK if it makes sense.
But here it seems, like,
a little arbitrary.
But it's not the
end of the world.
Does that makes sense why
that seems a little bit weird,
though?
Because it's like,
in your script
there is nothing that
sort of signifies
or identifies that you've
shot, like, at a different day.
Or that you're in a
location that requires
a different wardrobe, you know?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is a Koch snowflake.
This time, drawn on a computer.
Such never ending patters
that, on any scale,
on any level of zoom
look roughly the same
are called fractals.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, I'm
just going to say it.
How do you pronounce
Koch snowflake.
STUDENT 2: I think it's
"coke," but I don't know.
PROFESSOR: I'm pretty
sure-- it's K-O-C-H, right?
Just cause I would imagine
that it's educators watching
this video, but if there
are little children watching
this one, there are
going to be some,
ha, ha-- she said cock
snowflake comments.
STUDENT 1: I was
actually thinking
of doing-- because the
sound changes so much, I
was actually thinking of
doing a voiceover of this.
Because what I found-- I
recorded this part indoors
and outdoors, and I could
match up the sound perfectly
for what I was moving.
So if I, like, do the same
thing but somewhere else,
I can probably
match up the sound
and change the snowflake part.
PROFESSOR: Helge von Koch.
Yeah, I would just look
up the pronunciation
of that, just to--
STUDENT 1: OK, I will do that.
PROFESSOR: Just be careful.
Yeah, and especially-- this
is just video stuff anyway,
so you can easily
re-record that.
So wait for the reveal here.
Basically, do a little more
with cutting in and out
of close ups and wide shots.
OK, right here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --are called fractals.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So this reveal
is a little awkward,
because you're not
looking at the audience
when you're saying
the big reveal.
And then you have this
sort of unnatural pause
before you start
the next sentence.
STUDENT 1: OK, I was
actually originally intending
to say fractals
here, but I cut it--
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK, I see.
STUDENT 1: I thought, oh,
well I'll just say that.
But originally, it was going to
be I finished saying fractals,
and then I type on
the computer and say--
PROFESSOR: OK, that
will work a lot better.
STUDENT 1: So I
can just redo that.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
I mean, I think it's also-- I
think ideally, you would say,
fractals, and then you'd
look down at your computer.
But what you're saying
now, that'll work too.
STUDENT 1: And that's
how we filmed it, so--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
because this, like,
gap in where you take a
breath-- it sounds fine,
but it looks a little awkward.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Computer scientists can program
these infinite patterns--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So this is super
overexposed in the background.
So I would try to see if you
can bring the exposure down
just a little bit.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: I don't remember
how to do that on iMovie.
STUDENT 1: It's on this.
I actually increased
the exposure,
because there were some shadows.
But I can play around with that.
PROFESSOR: I mean, the main
thing is the whites, right?
Like, you're super
blown out in the window.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --infinite patterns
by repeating--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: No, it was
different in the original one.
PROFESSOR: I don't know if
there's a history on iMovie,
but if you can somehow just,
like, increase the blacks
but don't blow out
the whites, that
might help if you have
weird shadows going on.
STUDENT 1: I think-- so it
looked like this originally I
think.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's better.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, I don't know.
I was playing around with that.
But that's not
the final version.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
STUDENT 1: But that
was the original.
PROFESSOR: Got it.
Oh, yeah, I remember-- this one
also feels pretty long to me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Computer scientists can program
these infinite patterns my
repeating an often simple
mathematical process
over and over.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So, for that line,
do you have footage of you
on MATLAB graphing a fractal?
STUDENT 1: I can do that.
Because that would probably
be on the fractal software.
I can just--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, even that.
Like, just to break
it up a little bit
and give them, like,
a visual association.
Because this is one
of those times where
if you're like, again,
in static place saying
a big chunk of words to
them, it's sort of easier to
tune it out a little bit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --fractals.
Computer scientists can
program these infinite patterns
by repeating an often
simple mathematical process
over and over.
In the 1990s--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
then cut back out to you
when you say-- I mean,
because that's, like,
a very separate thought.
- --a radio astronomer
named Nathan Cohen--
PROFESSOR: Is there a picture of
Nathan Cohen that could, like,
pop up on the side?
STUDENT 1: I can
probably find that, yeah.
There is one, actually.
- --to revolutionize
telecommunications.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
So half way through the
video, you switch to these,
like, cube turn transitions.
I mean, this is a
personal preference.
I don't know how you
fell about transitions.
But I feel like, either
keep it all the same
or use, like, this a
little quirkier transitions
for a very pointed reason.
STUDENT 1: OK, for
this one, because it
was such different locations,
I used these to tell the story.
So this is me introducing the
story and telling the story.
So just for that story I'm
using those transitions.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I think if you're
going to do that, I much prefer
a push rather than a cube turn.
Because we've done
that once before,
and-- again,
personal preference.
George had to really
sell me on the idea,
because I was very
opposed to it.
But instead of doing a
rotation, you just-- it's
a wipe, basically.
One frame pushes off and
reveals the next one.
I think that looks
a little bit better.
STUDENT 2: Basically,
I prefer as subtle
of a transition as possible.
And the animations
are cool, but they
remind people of, like,
really flashy homemade videos
as opposed to
something professional.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, like this
is a very iMovie transition.
STUDENT 2: Yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-At ths time, Cohen was having
troubles with his landlord.
The man wouldn't let him
put an antenna on his roof.
So--
PROFESSOR: There's some-- wait,
let me listen to this again.
-Cohen was having troubles
with his landlord.
The man wouldn't let him
put an antenna on his roof.
So, Cohen designed a
more compact fract--
PROFESSOR: There
I would zoom in.
Cut to a closer framing up that
that's, like, just the wire.
- --radio antenna instead.
The landlord didn't notice
it, and it worked better
than the ones before.
Working further--
PROFESSOR: And then
cut come back out.
- --designed a new antenna.
This time, using the fractal
called the Menger sponge.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And again,
I don't think it's
necessary to do a rotation.
STUDENT 1: OK, and
I was thinking here,
while-- maybe have the Menger
sponge increase in size,
and then curtain
as a background.
So would that be
another transition,
to kind of have the
Menger sponge expand
and then have me wipe it off?
STUDENT 2: Are you
drawing a Menger sponge?
STUDENT 1: Going to have
a model of it, hopefully.
STUDENT 2: So you
are-- sorry, are
you going to re-film the
part with, like, a model?
STUDENT 1: No, just
like and image.
STUDENT 2: OK, OK.
PROFESSOR: So it would pop
up in your hand right there.
So the way this is
framed-- I mean,
the subject is really
here-- is going to be here--
and you're so biased.
I mean, this is
beautifully framed
in terms of, like, rule
of thirds and everything.
But because you held
your hand out this way,
it's going to look
really fun-- like,
the visual balance
of that frame is
going to look really funny when
you're like, Menger sponge,
and then all of a
sudden this huge thing
gets cut off on the side.
So either zoom in a
little bit-- ideally,
you would have held
out this hand so
that it would have
been in the middle.
Although the background
is really distracting,
so I don't know if--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Menger sponge.
The Menger sponge--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And are you
going to hold-- so,
I'm assuming the
Menger sponge picture
will be floating somewhere.
STUDENT 1: It would
be here, yeah.
But then I would
get rid of that when
I'm talking about
the regular sponge.
PROFESSOR: Well here it
would still be floating.
Because I think when you say,
the Menger sponge isn't exactly
like a real sponge, right?
But I think the Menger
sponge needs to be shown.
STUDENT 1: OK
PROFESSOR: If you're
going to show something,
show it long enough to
where the viewer can
process it a little bit.
Otherwise, it's like this
blip that might distract them.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PROFESSOR: Did you
cut right here,
or is there a little bit more?
STUDENT 1: I think
there's a little bit more.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
Hold it just a little bit,
and maybe cut to-- again,
cut to a close up shot.
That can be sort of a workaround
to the weird framing issue.
Otherwise it's like,
it's really nicely done.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The Menger sponge--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can
say, the Menger sponge,
and then pop up right there.
- --is not really the
sponge you'd be scrubbing
your bathroom with, but you can
still think of it like that.
Imagine both water and soap
getting through your sponge's
holes, except the water
is Wi-Fi and the soap is,
say, Bluetooth.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so here the timing
of you turning on the water
is a little bit weird.
Because you turn it
on, like, way after you
say water and soap.
And I wonder, were
you planning on doing
an animation for this section?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Imagine both water
and soap getting
through your sponge's holes.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Because
I feel like this
is a spot where
it actually would
be beneficial to not
even have an overlay,
but a completely separate
animation of, like,
a sponge with holes and,
like, H2O and soap with arrows
pointing.
Like, going into
the sponge holes.
What do you think, Zoe?
STUDENT 2: Yeah, or just to,
like, demonstrate that concept.
Because it's easier
to understand
when you read it than when you
hear it in a couple of seconds.
STUDENT 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And I think, like,
the visuals of this-- again,
it's a pretty long--
it's, what, 14 seconds?
It's actually kind
of long to have
the same sort of still framing.
STUDENT 1: If you
like how it's framed,
it's another-- you could
also just overlay like,
a little arrow pointing in.
Because you hold
it pretty still.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-But you can still
think of it like that.
Imagine both water and soap--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
like, you could just
have H2O and soap with arrows
pointing into the sponge,
and then coming
out of the sponge.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Except the water is Wi-Fi and
the soap is, say, Bluetooth.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah but
I would almost--
you can leave it in
for the rough cut
and we can see what
other people say.
But the movement
of that is almost
distracting, because
it has nothing
to do with what you're saying
when you're saying it, right?
Do you have another
take of this?
STUDENT 1: All of
them are kind of like.
PROFESSOR: Oh, the exact same.
OK.
STUDENT 1: There might be
one when I finish talking
and then turn on the
water, so I can use that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
if you cut it right here,
and you didn't
turn on the water,
then that would
have been better.
STUDENT 1: I think
there are versions
like that that I can use.
PROFESSOR: And again, this
one-- like, I wouldn't even
do it a push at all.
I really think it
looks a lot better when
you do as clean
transitions as you can.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The fractal's infinite
sponginess allows it--
PROFESSOR: I would shave off,
maybe, like a half second.
Because you take
a breath, and then
it takes just a hair before
you actually start talking.
So I'd just snip the tiniest
bit off of the beginning.
Are you planning on doing
any animations to the dies?
- --allows it to receive--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: I probably can put
them in the sponge, there.
And, like, signals
coming inside.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
otherwise-- again,
like, nice rule of thirds.
But you have a bath-- is
that a bathroom stall?
STUDENT 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it's
like a really awkward visual.
But if--
STUDENT 2: It's a
good background.
PROFESSOR: It's
a good background
if you want to put, like, a
picture of a Menger sponge
receiving different signal.
STUDENT 1: All right,
I can see that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Before Cohen's
invention, antennas
had to be cut for one frequency.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
show an old antenna.
-And that was the only
frequency they could operate at.
So--
PROFESSOR: And like, right here.
-So without Cohen's
sponge, your cell phone
would have to look
something like a hedgehog.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I would-- there's
like, a bit of a hesitation
before you say, "without
Cohen's sponge."
And I don't even
think you need the so.
So I would just
cut out the pause
and the so, and cut straight
to, "without Cohen's sponge."
And then to hide that
cut, you can either
zoom in little bit more--
STUDENT 1: OK, that makes sense.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
and like, for that,
since you're not going
to have the animation,
I would frame it and zoom
in to where it's just you.
And the resolution is going
to look a little funky,
but I think it's worth
the compromise to do that.
STUDENT 2: And it helps lead
to start leading the viewer
into seeing your phone.
Because it's like, you're
starting out with a wide shot,
and now you're on you,
and then eventually it
will be your phone.
And so it's like-- it just sort
of helps the narrative along.
PROFESSOR: And again,
I wouldn't ripple.
I would just go straight
to the cut into that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --multiple signals, including
the one your friends use when
they call.
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: So I'll take
out that transition.
PROFESSOR: This one you
could-- because it's
such a different--
wait, is that the end?
STUDENT 1: The end of the story.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, maybe
you can do a push.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Cohen later proved
that only fractal--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: But it's still
part of the same story,
so I would say just do
a clean cut there, too.
STUDENT 1: OK.
STUDENT 2: I like
that background.
PROFESSOR: But it is a
little-- it's still a little
overexposed here, too.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, that was
another one I edited as well.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
clean transition--
I would cut out this gap, too.
It's just like the
slightest-- it's
too long by just the
slightest amount of time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Cohen later proved that only
fractal shapes could work--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And that's
actually what makes
it read sort of newscastery.
You know, like, have you ever
seen the special segments,
and the reporter is on their
couch, and they're like,
da dah da dah da dah.
And then this person did this.
So it's just, like,
those tiny little gaps
that make it read that way.
But if you get rid of it, then
it will be a lot more natural.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --such a wide
range of frequencies.
Today, millions of wireless
communication devices,
including laptops and
bar code scanners,
use Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: So I'm going to
change that audio as well,
because I think I was too grand.
And I have other versions
that may work better.
PROFESSOR: OK, I like this a
camera slow pan off, actually.
STUDENT 1: We did
another version
which had also this pan.
It wasn't as good, but I said
the next sentence after that.
So it sounds more natural.
So I'm going to see
if I can trade off
the visual for better--
PROFESSOR: Do you
need something?
OK, sorry.
OK, so this is why this
transition is a little bit
funny here.
The speed at which you're moving
the camera when you pan off
is way faster than when
you pan down onto you.
So what you could do is
cut this clip into two,
and speed up the first part.
Like you did earlier.
Also, is this broccoli?
STUDENT 1: It is broccoli.
There's a mural, and stata.
PROFESSOR: I didn't
know that was broccoli.
It looked like bags
of seeds or something.
STUDENT 1: And maybe it
looked like broccoli enough.
PROFESSOR: It looks
like cauliflower.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Turns out, nature has--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: It actually
may be cauliflower.
I think I confused the
words when I was filming it.
So yeah--
PROFESSOR: IMovie, I hate you.
OK.
STUDENT 1: So if
you just press here.
PROFESSOR: I mean,
it's indistinguishable.
It looks like bags
of stuff almost.
STUDENT 1: I can still insert
just an image of broccoli,
so I don't-- if
it's not broccoli.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --devices, including
laptops and bar code scanners,
use Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the pan
just needs to happen sooner.
I would even speed the pan off,
and then speed up the pan down.
Right?
Cause it's like you're
waiting for the camera
to move off of you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Are you
planning on re-shooting
any of this for sure?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Turns out, nature has been
doing it the whole time.
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: Some scenes.
I can re-shoot this one, and
the one in the classroom.
The ones in east campus, I
don't think that I can do that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --organisms, often
of a fractal shape.
For example, the
spiral fractal is
present in broccoli,
seashells, and--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because I
think especially with this one,
go ahead.
STUDENT 2: Oh, I know-- I
think the broccoli-- the spiral
fractals are most present,
it's like romanesco broccoli
or something like that.
And so like,
PROFESSOR: It's a specific type.
STUDENT 2: And so people might
be confused, and like look
at their normal
broccoli, and like--
PROFESSOR: I would show a
picture of the romanesco
broccoli.
Especially because I
don't think this is-- I
think this is bags of
barley, or cotton almost.
STUDENT 1: That would
make more sense.
It's also why the
person is up there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
I think, also, it just
like doesn't really
look like a fractal.
Whereas the broccoli
actually-- there
are visualizations of it
where it actually looks like,
oh, I can identify
this as a fractal.
STUDENT 2: And so it will just
be reassuring for your viewer
when they can see the picture
of the broccoli and be like,
oh, I can totally see
how that's a fractal.
Rather than, like, squinting at
your background and being like,
is that-- did I learn anything
from this video type thing.
PROFESSOR: If you're going
to re-shoot this part--
and if you can't get it
this weekend, that's OK.
Remember, you still
have Wednesday to do it.
I would be careful about the
way you're emphasizing words.
It's kind of falling a little
into the trap of what George
was saying about how
news presenters emphasize
every third word, just a
sound sort of-- they're
emphasizing important
thoughts, but they don't really
make sense where they're
emphasizing the words.
So I would just try a few
different types of deliveries.
One where you're actually
emphasizing every other word
on purpose.
And then do something, like,
completely exaggerated.
And then try one where you're
sort of more natural tone
talking.
STUDENT 1: I think that's
how I usually present.
Like, even in real life.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --the whole time.
And not just with snowf--
fractals in the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Remember that
eighth grade PHD Thing.
You're talking for
eighth graders,
but you're not talking
necessarily to a 10-year-old,
right?
So how would you say this line--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Turns out, nature has been
doing it the whole time.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: How would
you say that line
to, like, your professor?
STUDENT 1: I mean, I wouldn't
say this line to my professor.
PROFESSOR: How would you
say that line to Jamie?
STUDENT 1: Turns out, nature has
been doing it the whole time.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a little bit different.
Like, turns out nature's
been doing it the whole time.
It's such a subtle nuance,
but it's just something
about, like--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- -- bar code scanners use
Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
Turns out, nature has been
doing it the whole time.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I think it's
the way you say time.
Nature has been doing
it the whole time.
I mean it's OK to
say the whole time,
but it reads like a
little Reading Rainbow
when the intonation
is like that.
But again, maybe that's
just my personal taste.
In general, I think your
enthusiasm is really, really
good.
Like, you're taking a subject
that's inherently a little bit
hard to visualize.
It's a little bit tedious.
And because you have this
enthusiastic delivery,
it's a lot easier to follow
along with you, which is good.
So don't lose any of
that energy, for sure.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And not just with snowflake.
Natural selection favors
the most efficient systems
and organism, often
of a fractal shape.
For example, the
spiral fractal is
present in broccoli,
seashells, and hurricanes.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: If you
re-shoot this, just
make sure that you're
framed more in the center,
and there's enough room
above you to accommodate
for the animations.
And this is actually something
that you could, if you had to,
you could do on your own.
You just set up the tripod
and flip the screen around you
so you could see.
You wouldn't have the
pan down, but that's OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The fractal tree is
relatively easy to program,
and can be used to study
river systems, blood
vessels, and lightening bolts.
So many--
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: Yeah, I
definitely don't think
there is enough space there.
But I wasn't the one directing.
PROFESSOR: The other
thing is, like,
if you end up filming
this part on your own
you don't necessarily
have to have a pan down.
You could just do a
push down transition.
That's where I feel like
a transition would be OK,
because you've got the
camera tilt up previously.
If you do this again,
I would just look up
instead of going like this.
Because it's a little bit
awkward to go like that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --natural systems
previously thought off limits
to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I wouldn't move
off of this scene so quickly.
Like, give it one more
beat before you transition.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --and can be used to study
river systems, blood vessels,
and lightening bolts.
So many natural
systems previously
thought off lim-- tree it is
relatively easy to program,
and can be used to study
river systems, blood
vessels, and lightening bolts.
[END PLAYBACK]
STUDENT 1: And I would
re-shoot this completely.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So many natural systems
previously thought off limits
to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
and right here I
would just cut to,
immediately, you talking.
Because there's, like, a
little bit too long of a pause
before you start.
And bump up the--
STUDENT 1: Yeah, I'll do
a voice over for this one,
because there's a lot of wind.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --learn nature's
best practices,
and then apply to solve
real world problems.
Much like Cohen's antenna
revolutionized the field
of telecommunications,
other fractal research
is changing medicine,
weather prediction,
and building design--
here at MIT and everywhere
in the world.
Look around you--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: When you
say, "look around you,"
I would actually cut back
to a close up of you.
Look around you--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What beautiful
patterns do you see?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And just end
it a little bit sooner.
It's a good start--
really good start.
STUDENT 2: A good
rule of thumb--
we never mentioned this
in the editing lecture,
but, like, you want to
give the end of a scene
a little room to breathe so
people can process, like,
what's going on.
And then at the
beginning of a scene,
you want it to be, like,
one or two frames before you
start talking.
So it's, like, almost
immediately your voice.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
actually a very good point.
And I should have brought that
up during the editing lecture.
But I feel like the tendency
is to do the opposite with what
you've done with the scenes
here, where you end too soon,
and then you wait
too long before you
start the next scene.
STUDENT 2: It's like--
it's counter intuitive,
but it makes it flow better.
PROFESSOR: But yeah,
you're in really good shape
in terms of, like,
pacing what you
need to do before next week.
So I think, at this
point, it's a matter
of getting the animations
in and the music.
STUDENT 1: OK, think you.
STUDENT 2: You're
definitely, like, well
on your way, on the
right track to be done.
PROFESSOR: This chair
is bad news bears.
I lean back to stretch,
and I'm still leaning.
I'm still leaning.
STUDENT 2: This entire
room is kind of--
PROFESSOR: It's a
little haphazard.
How are you guys doing?
STUDENT 1: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good luck.
You're still cutting
and pasting the script?
STUDENT 3: No--
PROFESSOR: Oh, your
scenes together.
You guys finished filming
everything, right?
STUDENT 4: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This is nice framing.
STUDENT 3: Thank you
See, you should--
PROFESSOR: Now, if
you did it again,
one cool thing
that you could do--
and I'm not saying that you
need to, because this is fine.
But if you had moved him to
the center of that picture,
and you moved close
enough, then this image
could basically fill
the entire background
and you wouldn't have
this weird gap, right?
STUDENT 3: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: I don't know if
the image was big enough
to do that, compared to
the size of his body.
STUDENT 3: The image
was big enough.
I didn't want to do that because
I didn't want him to look
like he was in green screen.
PROFESSOR: That's a
good point, actually.
That is a good point.
STUDENT 3: That's
the reason why.
I have a bit OCD,
so I can't stand
what's on the right, actually.
But I'm fine.
PROFESSOR: It's OK.
It's OK.
STUDENT 2: Yeah
it kind of-- it's
blurry enough that's
it's not distracting,
because I'm not trying
to read the words.
Because I don't think
they're, like, readable.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I wish
I could have given you
guys lights, because
that's what happens when
you rely on the fluorescent.
You get some weird shadows
on your face from overhead.
But it looks nice.
Do you guys have any
specific questions right now,
or should we just let you work?
STUDENT 3: I'm planning to
do animations all night, so--
PROFESSOR: I didn't see
you guys film anything.
I guess I saw you
guys film that stuff.
STUDENT 3: Like, I plan
to put animation here.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
definitely-- it's good.
That's a good surface.
As long as you keep the
pictures small enough.
STUDENT 2: And you can
adjust the size, like,
even after you've done
it After Effects--
and you've exported it or
transferred over to Premiere--
you can change the size of it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-How much faster would that be?
PROFESSOR: Did you guys
use the VIXIA for that one?
Did you use the
VIXIA in the hotel?
STUDENT 3: What is the VIXIA?
PROFESSOR: The Canon camera.
STUDENT 3: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's
like, nicely lit.
Surprisingly nicely lit.
So it's like a lot of
natural light, then.
Yeah, it looks really nice.
STUDENT 2: I think the
white bed sheets help,
because they're like
a natural reflector.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT 3: So they're
all natural light.
And there was a
lot of stuff here.
That we threw away.
I was like, oh,
I can't stand it.
It's too much.
PROFESSOR: And the
other thing is,
you might want to bring
the exposure down just
a tiny bit, because
the whites here
are really peaking pretty high.
But everything from
here is so nicely lit
that I'm almost inclined
to just, like, forget it.
Just keep it the way it is.
STUDENT 4: How do you
do the exposure on the--
PROFESSOR: In the
editing software
there should be a way to just,
like, bring down the exposure.
What are you using for yours?
STUDENT 3: I think
the simplest way would
be to tap the bright area,
and then it would be--
STUDENT 4: You mean on
the video camera itself?
STUDENT 3: Like, on the video
itself-- on the touch screen--
you just tap your shirt.
Then you will have dim down.
PROFESSOR: Nice job, guys.
STUDENT 2: You just kind of
disappeared for a couple days,
but you came back with
really good footage.
PROFESSOR: I'll let--
you guys can just work.
We'll stay out of the way.
STUDENT 2: If you have
any questions, then--
and I'll be able to answer,
like, any of the editing
questions you have in Premiere.
PROFESSOR: This one,
I would zoom in on you
a little bit more.
Because you're a little low.
So I would crop in like that,
to where the top of the frame
is just above your head.
STUDENT 2: Usually do the rule
of thirds with, like, eyes
rather than the top of head.
And I think.
And if you look at your eyes.
They're kind of in
the middle so you want
to adjust it so they're equal.
Yeah, like that.
PROFESSOR: We'll
let you guys work.
STUDENT 2: If that's
all let me [INAUDIBLE]
for today, actually.
STUDENT 3: What time is it?
STUDENT 2: It's 10 till 3:00.
STUDENT 3: OK.
STUDENT 2: OK, so now
what-- the problem
is, illustrator
defaults to a brush.
Which we don't
want, because that
will mess up when we
redraw it in After Effects.
So we select the arrow,
we want to change
Brush Definition to basic.
Go into Stroke-- let's see,
why are there not more options?
There we go.
Change the caps and
corners to round,
so it's, like, nice and smooth.
Like, it looks like a brush.
Basically, we're making
it look like a brush,
while doing a basic shape.
And then change it to, like,
whatever weight you want.
So you want it about that.
And you can play around.
Like, do you want
it super thick,
or do you want it not so thick?
And then the last
thing you need to do
before going into After Effects,
is go into this layer-- and so,
see, it has the different
parts of the arrow.
You want to highlight
everything, click this drop
down menu, and
click Reverse Order.
Because it stacks it
from the last thing you
drew to the first
thing you drew,
and you want to be first
thing you drew to last thing
you drew.
Then you want to save this.
We'll just save it
in Documents for now.
OK, and then you open
up After Effects.
PROFESSOR: That's
a nice pan, Joshua.
This is nice camera work.
STUDENT 3: Oh yeah, I held
the tripod to the right.
I looked really stupid, though.
STUDENT 2: But
it's really stead.
STUDENT 3: I didn't
actually hold it like that.
I knew that it would be bad.
STUDENT 2: If After
Effects would open, and not
give us the color wheel of
death, then I can show you.
I can get it.
I have my computer.
It's, like, open.
It's about half
an hour of video.
OK, After Effects-- hurray!
OK, so we're going to import our
composition as a composition.
All right, double click it.
I'm going to set it
to a white background,
just so we can see things.
And depending on-- if you
do it on the black portion,
you might want to set
the background to black
and have the arrow be in white.
Like, depending on how
you want it to look.
OK, so this is the fun part.
So we're going to turn the
arrow layer into shapes.
And then what we're
going to do is,
we're going to a
add a Trim Paths.
And basically what
that means is, it's
going to draw the line for you.
And then under Trim Paths we're
going to trim multiple shapes
individually.
Because that means-- so,
if you do it simultaneously
it'll draw the arrow-- like,
both lines at the same time.
So it'll start drawing the long
arrow and, like, the arrow head
at the same time.
And we don't want that.
So change it individually.
And then wherever
you want it to start
you turn the end down to zero.
Set your key frame.
And, say, we want it
to draw in two seconds.
You turn the end to 100.
And you go back to beginning
and you press space.
And it will draw the
arrow is as much time.
Is that like what
you wanted to do?
STUDENT 3: Yeah, I
wanted to do arrows.
STUDENT 2: Yeah, and
then you can change it.
Like there's some
lines-- like, I
like writing out handwriting a
lot in animations in my videos.
And so, like, for
example, if you
want it to pause on the
store, you can set it-- OK,
so it's like a 35%.
So you can set a key
frame there at 35%.
And then you can set another
one later on, also at 35%.
PROFESSOR: And then
what it does is it,
like, pauses at the
door, holds it there,
and then keeps going
in remaining time.
STUDENT 2: OK, thank you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I don't know
if you can remember all that.
But if you forget the rest of
it, write me and I'll redo it.
STUDENT 3: OK, thanks.
STUDENT 2: Yeah, let me know
if there's anything else.